every jab
takes the country closer to defeating
covid19
but worries continue that misinformation
is putting some off from having the
vaccine
and you can buy that misinformation in
bookshops
sky news has found that booksellers
water stones
amazon and foils are selling
anti-vaccine books
most of the reviews of this top seller
on amazon were posted
since march 2020 suggesting
purchases increased after the pandemic
began
many of them gave five star ratings of
the book
which is also sold by foils shadow
health minister
alex norris calls for retailers to do
more
i don't think it would be a solution to
you know burn the books or throw them
all away
because actually i think the mystique
would grow in that but instead
you know we'd really welcome a sense of
proportionate health warnings as
we've started to see emerge online
anti-vaccine books
are regularly appearing in the top 10
best sellers in the children's
vaccination category on amazon
in this recent screenshot half of the
top books
are promoting vaccine misinformation it
included one book
which claims data had been widely
manipulated and misrepresented
and that major safety questions have
gone unanswered about the vaccine
it's also available on waterstones
free speech campaigners say any calls
for these books to be banned
should be resisted almost anything can
potentially cause harm
under certain circumstances so if you
grant yourself that right you're
granting yourself the right to ban
almost anything sky news also found
other examples of medical misinformation
for sale
like this book which claims aids isn't
contagious
research has found 10 percent of
vaccine-related search results on amazon
led to products promoting misinformation
we also found out that
once users start engaging with
misinformation on the platform
they are presented with more
misinformation and at various points in
their
amazon navigation group all the authors
of the texts included in this report
deny that they are spreading
misinformation or our anti-vaccine
in response to our findings water stones
and foils said the books they sell
do not reflect the company's views while
amazon said
it encourages customers to read official
sources of information
and will remove products that breach
amazon's guidelines
samuel burgess sky news